destruction left behind by Cyclone Anton
as it ravaged parts of West Bengal
Odisha in India and southern Bangladesh
dozens have died and the numbers could
rise as more details emerge from rural
places even as it was downgraded from a
super cyclone to an extremely severe one
it made little difference as it slammed
into the homes of millions relief
operations expose the damage across the
region it is a slow process as
communication and electric lines are
down flood waters are everywhere the
Kolkata International Airport wasn't
spared either its hangers a twisted mess
and flooded
in a message on Twitter India's Prime
Minister Narendra Modi said no stone
will be left untouched have been seeing
visuals from West Bengal on the
devastation caused by cyclone open in
this challenging are the entire nation
stands in solidarity with West Bengal
praying for the well-being of the people
of the state as people salvage whatever
is left behind from their homes it will
be some time when the full extent of the
damage is known we went to the cyclone
center before the storm our house got
destroyed we're returning to our
neighborhood now to work and earn our
livelihood millions had to be evacuated
to shelters for safety this at a time
when the country is battling a pandemic
the loss will be felt for a long time by
the millions of poor as they resumed
their battle against the virus now Nevin
Lazarus Sky News India